to me when I see a kid wearing a Steph
Curry Jersey and that kid lives in New
York I think that gets soft if you have
to get motivated every single day then
you are in the wrong business the
journey the process is the reward for me
rise and shine it's in spresso time
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's start your day
off right together grab your coffee and
sip on today's message love the climb
over to you Gary Vaynerchuk also if you
want to know our Gary bean other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you in morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
on a bigger macro
patience and failure they all ladder up
to one thing which is insecurity I was
at the top of the wine game and I left
because I won I didn't want to do it
anymore and went into marketing where
everyone liked the first article written
about me was like this guy huh
wine Twitter I think the article in the
big advertising magazine was Twitter
boys what they call me Twitter boy
thinks he's gonna come and win Madison
Avenue hahahaha they're not laughing
anymore you know and even this game now
I can already feel it I'm like oh man
three four or five years from now this
thing's a rap I'm gonna be the guy some
would have to start selling oranges or
something you know I got to figure you
know I've enough to figure something out
because I lose like I'm about to climb
back to sports I grew up with diehard
Yankees Jets Rangers Knicks fan the
Yankees and Rangers won their
championships I literally stopped
watching them Knicks and Jets are gonna
take me a minute you know but like but
like I'm just about the color I just
love the climb like even like back to
sports cuz I think it's great analogy
I'll turn on a random game I need to
know who the underdog is that's my team
I'm just about to climb you know like to
me when I see a kid wearing a Steph
Curry Jersey and that kid lives in New
York I think that kid soft
I mean it he's he's using somebody
else's success to make himself feel good
I think the biggest tell of a losing
person is wearing a jersey outside your
own city if you have to get motivated
every single day then you are in the
wrong business if you're in your
business because you thought it was a
hot opportunity or a path to make some
quick money get out immediately shut it
all down you can't sustain motivation
for that business don't start a podcast
if you don't love talking or
interviewing with people don't become an
influencer if you have nothing to say
don't start a daycare if you don't love
kids it's not worth it and you're never
going to win the work itself needs to be
motivating most days you're gonna wake
up and have a pile of crap to deal with
and if you don't love dealing with that
crap you will get crushed by someone who
does enjoy dealing with that crap the
trick is you need to do work that you
love that other people think is crap
that's the secret so looking at my
channel as an example this YouTube
channel has grown from 7,000 followers
subscribers to 1.7 million in a matter
of four and a half years and I love the
climb and I love passing people on the
way and I love the competitive spirit of
it and I know there's still so much room
to grow but sometimes I secretly hope
that the whole thing goes away so just
so that I could start and do it again
I'm just short of sabotaging myself
although I have taken some some risks
recently if you look at my channel last
month or two months ago I did some major
changes that did not work I bet
everything on going down the premier
direction just because just because I
wanted to have some variety just because
I wanted to take a big bet and it tagged
hard and it was my worst subscriber gain
in in years and I loved it I loved it I
mean I don't love that I lost but I love
I love pushing I love trying to get
better I love climbing I love trying to
find a new way to be able to go and
build and get better and I think you
have to love the climb I'm just short of
massively sabotaging myself and closing
on the whole thing just to start over
but I
love the climb that much it's why I
loved Instagram I'm going hardcore
Instagram right now halfway through the
year I had six or seven or eight
something like that thousand followers
and now now I'm at almost 80,000
followers by still posting six times a
day and by going live five times a week
and by making three to eight to 20
stories a day and doing IG TV and all
that I love the client I love I love
when people look at my YouTube channel
and say you have 1.7 million subscribers
but you only have six thousand followers
on Instagram like what are you doing
you're a joke I love it I love it I love
I love looking at everybody who's ahead
and and having the ladder to climb up
again I love it all the people who I
pass on YouTube are all crushing me on
Instagram and I love it so much and it's
not doing it only to beat somebody else
it's just a competition I like the
competition
I like frequent things out I like I like
the hustle and the grind to try to win I
don't like being number one I like
chasing down number one you know I like
that there's always something ahead of
me to go and grow and chase and so I
think that has to be part of of the
entrepreneurial gene or DNA I like I
think I think having that competitive
spirit is essential and I think if you
are number one then you need to find a
way to reframe it now being at the top
of the game on the YouTube sides like
well how do I get to 10 you know how do
I get to 10 million and sometimes it's
hard because I don't see PewDiePie or
any of the guys who are like way ahead
of me as real competitors because we
talk about different stuff and so it's a
harder it's a harder leap but I have to
like to get excited about hitting 10
million I have to I have to start
thinking about who's ahead of me now and
like who's my next who's my next person
to run with it's me and Gary Gary right
it's me and Gary right we're 1 & 2
depending if you looking at views or
subscribers we're one in two minutes and
it's me and him button heads going back
and back and forth and I love it and so
I think you need it and you need to have
something where you feel like you are
growing every day you have to love the
work of the thing I love waking up and
looking at my youtube stats I love
waking up and looking at my videos I
love waking up and looking at my
comments I love being in the thing and I
think that's it you need to create
something that for anybody else it's
torture Jerry Seinfeld calls the torture
you can endure if you stepped into my
schedule it would be torture you would
want to get out of it as soon as
possible he couldn't last two days in my
schedule because it's just not you and
it's not because I'm great I should do
the same thing in your business if I
stepped into your schedule I should want
to die after two days like it's just too
much it's too crazy but it's not crazy
for you because you love it and that's
the thing everybody has Michael Jordan
level talent at something but most
people focus on the wrong thing most
people pick a business because it just
try to get rich and you hate the actual
process you love the result but you hate
the process you have to do the thing
that you love the process of that it
doesn't feel like work that you don't
need to motivate yourself to get up
every day and do because you can't wait
to get up and go do that thing I love
waking up and doing my YouTube and doing
my Instagram and wondering how that last
experiment worked and dive into the data
and do an a/b split test on the
thumbnails like all that stuff it's fun
for me it's fun that's why are you so
happy I mean because I love what I do
most days not every day this is all copy
got to deal with but I love doing with
all that stuff I love it and that's a
trick you got to find the thing that you
love the process of not just the end
results that you're chasing so I'm going
to give you a three step process to
making money and building a business off
of something that you love actually
doing not just trying to chase a buck
step number one is make a list of all
the ways that you have helped people and
made money doing it make a list like
write down all the things that you've
done that you've made money by helping
people if you're not helping people
you're not making money right business
is about helping people you bring value
you make money what are all the ways you
have made money by helping other people
in some form make a list step number two
then we're going to look at what did you
love the process of and not just a
result so the result was I helped them
and I made some money great it's a
win-win situation but which are the ones
on your list go and circle them or put a
star next to them or however you like
taking notes of the ones that you
enjoyed the process of like you enjoyed
it you enjoyed service in that client
you enjoyed selling that product or
service you enjoyed making that thing
that you actually enjoyed it if you're a
moving truck company you may enjoy that
you have helped somebody move to their
new place and you may enjoy that they
paid you and that's great but like did
you enjoy the movement did you did you
like seeing new places do you like it in
that side and getting at and you'd like
be able to work on your body and build
muscles your movements like do you like
it did you like you liked moving stuff
like the best movers loved moving
the best youtubers love making YouTube
videos the best hockey players love
playing hockey and put a star next to
our circle all the things on that list
that you created of how you've made
money helping people that you enjoy the
process of doing it and that you would
almost do for free you would do for free
because you loved it so much and then
September 3 with practice what do you
see that you could become world-class at
so look at that list of the ones that
you have made money from doing right
even if it's made on you lend me 100
bucks wait you made somebody doing it
then you start or circled it because you
enjoyed the process of how many of those
are left hopefully at least one
otherwise you got to start over or you
have to try more things right but then
then what do you see yourself being
world-class at like if you practice it a
lot could you become one of the best in
the world at you may not be there now I
mean it be there yet you may not putting
a lot of work at it yet maybe something
that just came naturally or it was an
opportunity that showed up and you said
yes to but you know that with some
practice with dedication with effort
with hustle with ongoing years and years
of beating on your craft you can become
the Michael Jordan of that industry what
is that thing and so when you combine
all three of those things that's when
you start making money from the thing
that you're passionate about when you
one figure out what have you made money
from by helping people when you two then
look at which of these tasks have I
actually enjoy doing not just I enjoy
getting paid to do it and then number
three which of these can you actually be
world-class at do you have Michael
Jordan level talent at figure that out
and you are on your way to building an
unstoppable impactful business now I've
got a really special bonus cut for you
but before that question of the day I
want to know what do you see yourself
being world-class at let me know put it
in the comments below
success for me is the process and I've
realized that every time in life where
I've sort of reached a been a benchmark
that's enabled me to pause when I pause
a misery yeah I hate it I hate it when I
sold my HBO series and I had two years
before it aired I was miserable didn't
know exactly and I don't like that so I
think that like it the journey the
process is the reward for me so like
right now starting something new this is
the most successful time in my life and
whatever this yields like when that
takes it or however it might manifest
takes place like sure that's great and
it's a cool story but it doesn't equal
happiness right like beam the most
exciting part of starting a tech company
was you know when it was my my Matt
Hackett my co-founder and I just the two
of us sitting in a room trying to figure
out that to me was like the pinnacle of
success you know when I was at MIT it
was like sitting in that lab every
single day across from these brilliant
minds that was the that was success for
me so the journey is what I strive for
and it's what excites me the most and
with three six eight it's like it's
really building to enable that journey
as much as possible I'm not focused at
all on a finish line there is no let's
raise a hundred million dollars of
venture money and existing a unicorn I
could get like this nothing I feel like
I feel like the finish line is like
every day for you
like every day restarts and it's there's
no real yeah I mean the the journey is
the reward this is where trainers mess
people up I've had trainers who totally
just want to prove that you could never
do what they do and they have you pay
and then go to blast you like they want
you unless you're in pain and you feel
like you're sick and you're throwing up
yeah that's a workout no yeah you look
at you yeah you hurt you hurt you can
walk great yeah and the whole point is
what I tell people is treat the gym like
a spa the first time you ever go just go
in there and walk around touch the
weights get a drink of water walk around
and then leave and and I mean literally
do that for like a week two weeks until
you just get to the habit of getting in
that door because what's gonna happen is
eventually you gotta start looking
because you're there yeah and you're
gonna do something and then you stop
don't
we get to the point where you're like I
can't be like it doesn't work I've been
working people want they say they want
my body and all this stuff but I've been
working out consistently since I was 14
years old and I'm 44 I've thirty years
of hard core to our workout 30 years
yeah so it doesn't happen overnight you
just have to enjoy the process
totally learn to enjoy it cuz I'm sure
there was a point where you started to
enjoy using a hundred thirteen pound yep
and that's the only way you're gonna
keep going and if you want more Gary
Vaynerchuk check out the last top fifty
rules video I made on him the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there technology and the way we
live doesn't care about my opinion or my
feelings and it doesn't care about yours
either